good afternoon later thank you again
for days that no good if I
don't want to talk to you about well that
will be the first time the first video
on this matter of the problems they
have when they learn English test and
why
the
Spanish-speaking of the  Chinese Japanese
offers the same more or less the
same problems with the English language
which is a language that has certain
characteristics that particularities
like it has every day that I have
made today of a language of a video about
there and why why  why why he
always makes mistakes with this well yes
and I had a lot of people notice that there are
edges
why are you bored if in bowling
it's not good for example of pits
boring the book this is a
boring ear well then if you feel
boring it's not how it is it's the feeling
good it doesn't interest me at all it's not
boring in this sense yes ok but in
english if you say there is in bahrain this
means that
the other people  Some think that you
are bored
but if there is no burning I have
nothing interesting for me if I came to
Bahrain but I think you did not make a
person who is going to say ah jamboree no longer
in Spanish no no no
the book is very  interesting
but
there are 20
sun
the movie is
there is a movie site
there is no sun
in that
iuc video in which you can read the
explanations you don't take off what
will remember you and you turn that no but in
the orchard not a year ago is to read  the
grammar the grass does not hurt you can
but it is very difficult to remember all
the explanations and all the rules it was
very very difficult and if when you are
talking you are going to
try to remember the rules
finally not being able to speak you are not going to put
one why not  It flows, it doesn't flow, so you
have to become avilés
habits
more or less because if not, not because
making mistakes in any
language is not a big problem. I make
mistakes in all languages, including
English
- in English it's not a problem.  Serious problem -
Spain Spanish what you have to
get used to getting used to getting used to
because in Portuguese is getting used to
another problem in speaking so many languages
you have to create
a habit a habit habits and this is
done through reading and listening
but when I for example  because the
armchairs that I am learning, for
example, in Russian, which has many
grammar problems, very complicated rules,
I go online soto line open up on
it
underline underline underline to be able to
see well I am going to I am going to save to
save to save
and with  a tactics I am going to study this
as in a list with examples good a
concentration of examples to be
able to create it never memorize it is a
matter of memorizing it is not that it is a
matter of creating habits and if for that
example if ever you are going to  put you
are reading in a book and you to
underline to underline about again about
and you will be able to find out what good
again you to listen to a c  dare
here there is the same the same thing that
of the phrase well that's why you have to
help the brain to realize now and
well if you realize later little by
little you will get used to it this
is more important and what  all the
explanations and to visualize it the
times to count more times in more
context more context in 3d
another phrase another expression and each time you
have to make an effort to
realize this is an example of something
that gives me problems in the language and  little
by little
perhaps that now you don't realize it
but you can export yourself to realize
it and find out if it can
also be done on a day-to-day basis and many times
it is already important another
other example with this there is in you when
you
said
to the hard to  stop to be in spain to
concentrate on it he
said why didn't you say you said
i said
in turin
there is no reason jürgen stark turin and to
be fine and winston but he is a doctor and
you cannot be and no not
this turin means that  I and  I am
marching and I stop
but to read something there is not your link but it
is printing to
finish the terminal stop
reading us
this is not sure that there are a lot of
explanations of the phenomenon in the language
but it is not possible to remember all that
now so you have to  read a lot listen a
lot and it is impossible every time you see
something interesting to force yourself to
underline to underline to find out if
not creating links and creating
taxis do not turn labels into
labels to force the brain brain
of the first time because like all
mistakes I make in Spanish
any language and it's not just
once I'm not going after a collection
I'm not going to make the same mistake the
second time the third time
little by little the brain will
get used to it this is the most important thing
to read  the explanations help
maybe it helps maybe it doesn't help
but more than anything else you have to read and
listen and make an effort and realize
what is happening in the language
and I c  I think so
and all the people who are learning
English are always good with these tips
that help us improve little by little
[Music]